In this video, we'll create a
basic scatterplot using ggplot.
Let's start by
reading in our data.
We'll be using the
same data set we
used during week one, WHO.csv.
So let's call it WHO and
use the read.csv function
to read in the
data file WHO.csv.
Make sure you're in the
directory containing
this file first.
Now, let's take a look at
the structure of the data
using the str function.
We can see that we have 194
observations, or countries,
and 13 different variables-- the
name of the country, the region
the country's in, the
population in thousands,
the percentage of the
population under 15 or over 60,
the fertility rate or average
number of children per woman,
the life expectancy in years,
the child mortality rate,
which is the number of children
who die by age five per 1,000
births, the number of cellular
subscribers per 100 population,
the literacy rate among
adults older than 15,
the gross national
income per capita,
the percentage of male children
enrolled in primary school,
and the percentage of
female children enrolled
in primary school.
In week one, the very
first plot we made in R
was a scatterplot
of fertility rate
versus gross national income.
Let's make this plot again,
just like we did in week one.
So we'll use the plot function
and give as the first variable
WHO$GNI, and then give
as the second variable,
WHO$FertilityRate.
This plot shows us that
a higher fertility rate
is correlated with
a lower income.
Now, let's redo
this scatterplot,
but this time using ggplot.
We'll see how ggplot can be
used to make more visually
appealing and
complex scatterplots.
First, we need to install
and load the ggplot2 package.
So first type
install.packages("ggplot2").
When the CRAN mirror
window pops up,
make sure to pick a
location near you.
Then, as soon as the
package is done installing
and you're back at
the blinking cursor,
load the package with
the library function.
Now, remember we need
at least three things
to create a plot using ggplot--
data, an aesthetic mapping
of variables in the data
frame to visual output,
and a geometric object.
So first, let's
create the ggplot
object with the data and
the aesthetic mapping.
We'll save it to the
variable scatterplot,
and then use the
ggplot function, where
the first argument is the
name of our data set, WHO,
which specifies the data to
use, and the second argument
is the aesthetic mapping, aes.
In parentheses,
we have to decide
what we want on the x-axis and
what we want on the y-axis.
We want the x-axis
to be GNI, and we
want the y-axis to
be FertilityRate.
Go ahead and close both sets
of parentheses, and hit Enter.
Now, we need to tell
ggplot what geometric
objects to put in the plot.
We could use bars, lines,
points, or something else.
This is a big difference between
ggplot and regular plotting
in R. You can build
different types of graphs
by using the same ggplot object.
There's no need to learn
one function for bar
graphs, a completely different
function for line graphs, etc.
So first, let's just create a
straightforward scatterplot.
So the geometry we
want to add is points.
We can do this by typing the
name of our ggplot object,
scatterplot, and then adding
the function, geom_point().
If you hit Enter, you should
see a new plot in the Graphics
window that looks similar
to our original plot,
but there are already a
few nice improvements.
One is that we don't have the
data set name with a dollar
sign in front of the
label on each axis, just
the variable name.
Another is that we
have these nice grid
lines in the background
and solid points
that pop out from
the background.
We could have made a
line graph just as easily
by changing point to line.
So in your R console, hit
the up arrow, and then just
delete "point" and type
"line" and hit Enter.
Now, you can see a line
graph in the Graphics window.
However, a line doesn't
really make sense
for this particular plot,
so let's switch back
to our points, just by hitting
the up arrow twice and hitting
Enter.
In addition to specifying that
the geometry we want is points,
we can add other options,
like the color, shape,
and size of the points.
Let's redo our plot with blue
triangles instead of circles.
To do that, go ahead and hit
the up arrow in your R console,
and then in the empty
parentheses for geom_point,
we're going to specify some
properties of the points.
We want the color to be equal
to "blue", the size to equal 3--
we'll make the points
a little bigger --
and the shape equals 17.
This is the shape number
corresponding to triangles.
If you hit Enter, you
should now see in your plot
blue triangles
instead of black dots.
Let's try another option.
Hit the up arrow again, and
change "blue" to "darkred",
and change shape to 8.
Now, you should
see dark red stars.
There are many different
colors and shapes
that you can specify.
We've provided some information
in the text below this video.
Now, let's add a
title to the plot.
You can do that by
hitting the up arrow,
and then at the very end
of everything, add ggtitle,
and then in parentheses
in quotes, the title
you want to give your plot.
In our case, we'll
call it "Fertility Rate
vs. Gross National Income".
If you look at your
plot again, you
should now see that it has
a nice title at the top.
Now, let's save
our plot to a file.
We can do this by first
saving our plot to a variable.
So in your R console,
hit the up arrow,
and scroll to the
beginning of the line.
Before scatterplot,
type fertilityGNIplot
= and then everything else.
This will save our
scatterplot to the variable,
fertilityGNIplot.
Now, let's create a file we
want to save our plot to.
We can do that with
the PDF function.
And then in parentheses
and quotes, type the name
you want your file to have.
We'll call it MyPlot.pdf.
Now, let's just print our plot
to that file with the print
function -- so
print(fertilityGNIplot).
And lastly, we just have to type
dev.off() to close the file.
Now, if you look at the
folder where WHO.csv is,
you should see another
file called MyPlot.pdf,
containing the plot we made.
In the next video,
we'll see how to create
more advanced
scatterplots using ggplot.